bush stadium the scene a muggy night and
there is dakota hudson with a record of
two and two in his six starts this
season coda hudson has been throwing the
ball very very well got the win last
time out on sunday against the cubs
shugo akiyama has really been kind of
coming into his own here recently hit up
the middle de young to his left one away
[Applause]
and a ground ball third baseman matt
carpenter
two away
one of the mistakes adam wainwright made
was to joey votto hit a home run and
this is lifted out to center backing up
bader
he'll make the catch in a one two three
you've got some pretty professional
hitters in that lineup they will make
you work they will make you throw
strikes and that will be a challenge for
tj antone 2-2 pitch
swing and a miss it's a nasty hook and
we've seen that big time hook from
antone before if that's working look out
that'll bring up paul goldschmidt with a
runner on one out fly ball right field
stiano's towards the line
two down brad miller will stride to the
plate 275 five homers and it's a
breaking ball weekly roll to the right
side freddie galvez has to charge it and
the cardinals are done in the first
that's four up four down and it brings
in brian goodwin swing and a miss first
strikeout for dakota here's a 3-2 pitch
it's a strike called and down goes uh
galveston that's uh two strikeouts in
the inning and two in the game for the
cardinal starter hudson mr austin dean
he gets to start tonight
he's all for one here's a shot deep in
the left center and it gets down and
goes all the way to the wall and a great
advantage austin dean and he chugged
into second base without a play austin
dean wants more playing time first and
second two outs harrison bader the
batter 2-2 pitch
strike three called nasty breaking ball
and dakota hudson after retiring the
first six batters he faced he has now
walked aquino barnhart and farmer to get
it back to the top of the order and
shogo akiyama
on the ground
be tough to turn two they get the out at
second base but it'll plate aquino and
the reds have a one-nothing lead well
now first and third for castianos on two
and two the pitch
swinging a ground ball to third
carpenter throws to second out wong to
first double play
that could have been a whole lot worse
three walks to open the inning one
scored paul goldschmidt is up goldsmith
five home runs and 15 rbis now the
payoff pitch
anton getting filthy
here's brian goodwin goodwin struck out
swinging the first time up the wind up
the 1-2 pitch
swing and a miss goodwin strikes out
reds are on top one to nothing as the
cardinals bad in the fourth inning it's
miller de young and carpenter is miller
lifts it in the air center field and
this ball is gone
what did that carry way out of here into
center and miller is tied at 1-1 with a
solo homer who's just talking about if
you're going to swing it swing it go for
bro go for broke and he did that went
down to get it solo home run
brad miller his sixth of the year
that does not look like your
prototypical home run swing okay
446 feet paul flies off his back lucas
sims comes into a tough spot the bases
will be loaded for matt wieters and
wieders hits it up the middle a diving
stop and
he is out at first but the cardinals
pick up a run and they pick up a lead
it's now two to one saint louis a
tremendous player but that saved at
least one run two-out matter joey vano
botto down the left field line this is
the reds first hit
ottawa on his way to second base
and the tying run in scoring position
vadawa's lead from second two down here
top of the sixth in the air hit well
to the track
and just missing it is suarez carpenter
singled
in that two-run cardinal fourth
carpenter with a drive out to deep right
field it's at the wall gone
into the cardinal bullpen
carpenter's third home run of the season
and it's now a three
st louis lee amir garrett on the mound
to pitch for the reds runners at first
and second nobody out and he is 15 for
15 at retiring the first batter faced
his first batter is the cardinal number
nine hitter harrison bader and the 2-0
pitch lifted in the air deep right
center at the wall
gone
three-run homer opposite way
harrison vader off of garrett
three-run shot busted open for the
redbirds
and now goldschmidt
cartel's been waiting for that big
inning kind of been pushing it a couple
of times but hadn't been able to get
anything real going
that's it out to deep right field at the
wall office it field home run
goldsmith
the cardinals have hit
their fourth home run tonight it's 7-1
st louis
they're feeling it right now dan i got
to be honest i can get used to this
stuff i mean i'm fine with the small
ball change places stuff but if you just
want to hit a bunch of home runs
we're fully behind this as well oh yeah
and he strikes out joey votto
who has had
words with the home plate umpire the
entire night
to his credit dj never mind
i think joey votto says i vehemently
disagree
with the call and the one-two
hit out to left field
and the catch made by tyler o'neill
cardinals showing off a little power in
this ball game dan got great pitching
everything that you'd want to see